Pope Francis is in Ireland this morning
for the first visit by a pope in almost
four decades to one of Europe's most
Catholic countries the visit comes amid
global condemnation of the church's
handling of sex crimes rocking the
church
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Dublin good
morning Jonathan good morning and the
Pope speaking for the first time inside
the Dublin Castle behind me where he
took a brief moment in that speech to
address child abuse in churches
specifically here in Ireland he called
them crimes but most noticeably absent
from that speech any reference to the
abuse allegations in Pennsylvania the
Pope's weekend visit to celebrate
Catholic faith and compassion has been
overshadowed by the explosive grand jury
report in Pennsylvania cataloguing abuse
by more than 300 priests the last Pope
to visit Ireland was John Paul the
second in 1979 who was greeted then by
two and a half million faithful five
times the crowd expected for Pope
Francis and I believed him I don't
really meant something to me and a year
and a half later I was raped by a priest
for the first time and that continued
for two and a half years Tom oar Gorman
says he was abused when he was 14 years
old and they covered up those crimes and
they allowed them to go unchecked a
series of abuse allegations have taken
their toll in Ireland one of the most
Catholic countries in the world church
attendance has plummeted in May abortion
was legalized in what many called a
referendum against the church Irish nun
Liz Murphy who we sat down with earlier
this week said if the church is to
survive it will need total reform if
he's a very male masculine institutional
top-down dictatorial body who wouldn't
want as a woman to see that collapse and
Ireland's first gay prime minister also
had some tough words he spoke directly
to the Pope inside the castle behind me
telling the Pope that he must adhere to
a zero tolerance policy
against church abuse and also demanding
the Pope take action Anthony Jonathan
Vigliotti in Dublin for us this morning
Jonathan thanks so much